[Music]
people clutching their last few dollars
might find themselves on the brink of
despair
that puts them at risk of slipping into
psychological poverty traps
vicious cycles of financial distress and
mental illness building on one another
making poverty and disorders like
depression harder and harder to escape
freeing people from these traps requires
inexpensive solutions
on a large scale hoping to inform these
solutions
a new review in science highlighted
studies that examine psychological
poverty traps
with a few exceptions much of the
research took place in developing
countries
when changes in policy or climate
affected people's financial standing and
mental health
one study in indonesia compared
depression and suicide rates
among different villages receiving cash
transfers from a government program
a model based on census data estimated
1065 fewer suicides
occurred in the villages that were first
to get cash
the same study tracked the village's
rainfall totals which can affect farmers
incomes
villages that got lots of rain had less
depression and suicide than
drought-stricken areas
another program in oregon chose a group
of low-income adults
by lottery to receive free health
insurance worth 500 to 750
after a few months insurance lottery
winners
were 25 percent less likely to have
depression
in addition to studies linking income
changes to depression
the review noted the other side of the
coin
low-cost depression treatments that
improved economic outcomes
a randomized trial in goa india tested
the effects of cognitive behavioral
therapy on depressed adults
many of them unemployed at a cost of 66
dollars per person
lay counselors encouraged people to
focus on activities they enjoyed
say gardening or music to ease their
negative thoughts and attitudes
a control group of other adults receive
more traditional medical attention
such as primary care visits after 12
months
adults in the experimental group were 60
percent more likely to have recovered
and they worked on average 2.3 more days
a month
giving them the chance to make more
money in pakistan
pregnant women volunteered for a similar
program that offer cognitive behavioral
therapy from lay counselors
a control group simply received visits
from primary care doctors
who advise them on issues like
immunizations and breastfeeding
after just six months women receiving
therapy were less than half as likely to
be depressed as the control group
seven years later they had also gained
more say
in their family spending decisions their
children even ended up attending better
schools
suggesting the therapy's benefits might
span generations
programs like the ones in india and
pakistan have since been adapted to
treat maternal depression
in the united states and canada
the reviews findings indicate that
policy has a real effect
on breaking psychological poverty traps
a reminder that it's possible
to intervene and reduce mental and
financial hardship
you